sehr oft genauso wie sich das gehört
wirklich sehr sehr weich man kann es
auch so auseinander freeman das finde
ich auch schön sieht das als süßes brot
das sehr sehr flüssig ist
[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben wir waren in auf seine
insel waren auf mallorca und da habe ich
in siders kennen gelernt und habe mir
gedacht warum gibt es die über alzheimer
das ist ein mallorquinisches gebäck und
zwar ist es so ein luftiges hefegebäck
ganz typisch mit schweineschmalz das
wusste ich nicht bevor ich mir das
gekauft habe ich habe nur gesehen jeder
am flughafen rennt mit diesen kartons
rum ich will es auch haben und sein
bedeutet aber schweineschmalz oder
schmalz und das ist ganz typisch viel
schweineschmalz drin ist daher liebe
sarah schenk ich dir
und wir machen aber ich kann es jetzt
kein geschmack sondern machen aber ich
habe vor ort auch in einer bäckerei wo
die noch selber backen da habe ich auch
ins einmal ausprobiert und waren sehr
sehr lecker was machen wir heute so
lange rede kurzer sinn wir machen vieles
hefegebäck aus mallorca und ich habe
jetzt hier meine küchenmaschine könnte
auch ein handrührgerät verwenden und ein
paar zutaten ist echt ich viel also wir
brauchen ein bisschen mehr
die milch habe ich in der mikrowelle ein
bisschen erwärmter werd ich vorab quälen
und dann machen den schönen hefeteig aus
trockenhefe und ein bisschen zur
kampagne extrakt
[Musik]
so in der maschine ist jetzt schon mal
ein bisschen habe ich mir an die seite
gegeben da kann man später immer noch
was dazu fügen aber umgekehrt also was
wegnehmen sobald die flüssig zutaten
drin sind es war ein bisschen schwierig
die lauwarme milch ist drin ihr könnt
auch schon zucker und trocken gehen mit
dazu geben also sitzen ganz entspannt
das rezept und es schmeckt natürlich am
besten wenn es richtig schön frisch ist
und die mallorquina essen das zum
frühstück das dann immer schön in ihren
kaffee und ich glaube so mach ich es
heute auch man in der extrakt ihre ich
hier einfach da wo die milch ist schon
mit dazu dann versendet sich das besser
und die facc wählten eier und wenn ihr
mögt noch eine richtig dicke prise salz
die hebt noch mal den süßen geschmack
und dann lasse ich das einfach kneten
erst mit der maschine und später mit den
hängen
[Musik]
also ich hab den teig die jetzt ein paar
minuten kneten lassen wir ungefähr drei
bis vier minuten der ist noch sehr
klebrig ich habe tatsächlich auch mein
ganzes mehrverbrauch das kommt halt
wirklich immer auch auf die größe der
eier einmal brauchte mehr und mal
weniger ich nehme das mal den mit
klebrigen teilt raus auf die
arbeitsfläche und dann kommt noch mehr
mehl dazu und jetzt ist eben der moment
wo er einfach mit den händen viel besser
arbeiten können und gucken können ist
derzeit so weit braucht ihr noch ein
bisschen mehr oder noch viel viel mehr
und ich habe auch habt ihr bestimmt
unten in der video beschreibung gesehen
da stehen denn die ganzen genauen
mengenangaben ich benutze in diesem
video weizen jeder typ 550 das ist das
bak starke mail und das hat etwas mit
dem klebereiweiß zu tun den clip
eigenschaften und da habt ihr einfach
den vorteil dass der teig durch dieses
mail einfach mehr elastizität hat und
dann ist das ergebnis auch umso besser
[Musik]
also ihr werdet merken dass der teig
zwar jetzt fester wird also ihr könnt
auch oben anpassen ohne dass euch da
direkt was kleben bleibt aber es ist
dennoch ein klebriger teil das seht ihr
hier und wenn ihr das anlegen möchte
dass der so ein bisschen widerspenstig
ist jetzt würde ich an der stelle kein
nebel hinzufügen und einfach nur ein
bisschen weiche butter nehmen in die
handinnenflächen das heißt ein bisschen
das ist schon echt viel aber gleich
kommt noch mehr spätere zum einsatz der
mir das ganze ausbreiten das zeige ich
euch aber und jetzt einfach noch mal mit
den
eingebürgerten händen so ein bisschen zu
einer kugel rollen benetzen und dann
zurück in die schüssel geben und dann
muss der teig eine stunde an einem
warmen ort ziehen erziehen gehen weil
ich
[Musik]
so die gehzeit ist um und wir können
unserem teig ausrollen stützen jetzt
hier direkt auf meine back matte und
dann relativ groß also ich würde schon
sagen wo 40 mal 40
ungefähr hat also solche relativ groß
und rechteckig werden butter ist auch
schöne zimmer waren die kommt jetzt zum
einsatz denn nachdem wir die details
schon ausgebreitet haben wie bei
zerschnitten wird der komplett mit
butter eingestrichen und dann eingerollt
und dann kommt die schöne form
[Musik]
[Applaus]
teig ist aufgeräumt ich habe hier mein
lochblech mit einem backpapier oben
drüber und jetzt gilt es diesen sehr
weichen teig noch mal so ein bisschen zu
zwirbeln wenn ihr könnt wenn ihr mögt es
hat optisch schöner und dann zu einer
schnecke form achtung ihr dürft diesmal
die schnecken nicht eng rollen sondern
lasst bewusst ein bisschen platz damit
er im ofen halt noch mal schön aufgehen
kann
[Musik]
so meine ensheimer da durfte jetzt bei
180 grad ober und unterhitze für 28
minuten bräunen ein bisschen butter
tritt aus das ist normal das ist auch
gar nicht stimmt das auch wirklich nicht
viel und ich habe das jetzt einfach mal
an ich habe es jetzt 15 minuten
ausdampfen lassen
wir wollen da jetzt ganz traditionell
natürlich auch puderzucker drauf machen
und nicht zu wenig also nicht sparen und
dann gönne ich mir das gleich mit einem
café ich freue mich den ganzen tag schon
drauf falls euch wundert warum ich jetzt
was anderes an habe wir sind ja immer
super flower brains hier und drehen
halten natürlich mehrere videos an einem
tag also heute zwei und damit sich
manchmal was anderes an zwar ist er dann
anderes video ist erstens kannst du das
denn auch unterscheiden wenn im schnitt
also die zeit die ich jetzt alles an und
gegen ende bin ich dann immer zuvor mich
nochmal umzuziehen wo ist das unser plan
gar nicht aufgegangen heute aber egal
auf jeden fall ist das jetzt unsere
fertige ensheimer da ich finde die sieht
einfach gut aus ich möchte den text es
hat auf jeden fall mit hamza zusammen
machen ist gerade im shop und er ist
auch gleich da in der zwischenzeit
machen wir wunderschöne fotos und
entziehen und gleich sehen uns im test
ist wieder
[Musik]
kiki spruch hier noch ein bisschen du
musst den test auf jeden fall eine
machen
ich habe im kopf bekommen egal ich mache
den test ist jetzt dafür alleine nicht
schlimm ich brauchen immerhin haben sie
neben mir auf und ich mich gefreut hat
also ich werde jetzt ganz traditionell
wie jemand der auf mallorca lebt meinen
insider in kaffee trinken
stellt euch vor ihr seid grad in palma
für euch der strand ihr habt euren café
auf dem mallorquinischen insel wetter
als toll 30 grad im schatten und jetzt
könnt ihr euch euer in samara
sehr soft genau so wie sich das gehört
wirklich sehr sehr weich wie butter raus
man kann es auch so auseinander freeman
das finde ich auch schön diese einzelnen
schichten mit dem café finde ich toll
also gefällt mir richtig gut dass er so
rein zu tunken und ansonsten bin ich der
meinung es schmeckt am ersten tag am
allerbesten am nächsten tag kann man es
gerne auch noch einmal aufwärmen aber
spätestens dann sollte man das wirklich
auf essen wenn ihr das jetzt auch noch
machen möchte dann schaut in die infobox
da stehen alle ganzen mengenangaben und
eigentlich müsste ich mir jetzt mit
calado wohl das mache ich auch gleich
und er das ist nämlich auch als typisch
einfach mit marmelade oder mit irgend
eine creme bestreichen seht das als
süßes brot das sehr sehr flüssig ist und
viele auf mallorca machen es ja auch so
dass die das am vortag vorbereiten denn
lassen diesen kühlschrank gehen die
kalte führung nennt man das dann von dem
nächsten tag backen sie das dann aus und
genießen das schön warm also ich hoffe
das rezept hat euch gefallen ich wünsche
euch ganz viel spaß und nach machen wie
gesagt ich könne mir das jetzt auch in
aller ruhe und sage mal bis zum nächsten
mal typen ski team
[Musik]